hallo mein name ist super und ich habe
instagram folgt den wir da eigentlich
schon schoss aber auf jeden fall bin ich
nicht der einzige user auf instagram
sonst wäre die plattform relativ traurig
sondern es gibt auch noch ein paar
millionen andere instagram account wie
hier beispielsweise bickschlag
und hier in
und einen lamborghini dieses bereits im
titel eingeblendet wir schauen uns heute
die ersten instagram bilder
verschiedener youtuber an
ich würde sagen als erstes fangen wir
mal mit meinem eigenen account an das
scrollen jetzt erst mal so ein bisschen
runter ich habe 267 hochgeladene
beiträge dhb scrollt jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen 2000 jahre später ich bin jetzt
hier unten angekommen und zwar ist das
hier mein erster instagram beitrag
hashtag pulli klauer hashtag strafakte
heftig aktiv wie hell steck empfehlung
hashtag nein
und dann habe ich chris verlinkt wtf und
wie sehe ich da bitte aus als zweiter
youtuber habe ich mir hier julien beer
ausgeprägt man sieht direkt dass er hier
eine ganz andere qualität hat was seine
bilder angeht werde auf jeden fall
weniger hochgeladen hat sich also gegen
die 194 stück das heißt dass gold jetzt
ja auch
o
da ist es schon dieses bild hatte in
etwa genau vor vier jahren hochgeladen
und da ist er am shisha rauchen mensch
julien das aber ungesund und hatte das
netz schott es heißt giulia ich weiß
dass es auch das wort gibt es die
nächste youtube in die wir uns mal
anschauen werden sie hat fast 1000
beiträge rokita die beine ewigkeit
später
es macht spaß
ich sehe gerade dass ich nicht mal
meinen eigenen wlan grad drin bin und
ladet ihr gerade fünf milliarden bilder
von buddy wir haben das erste bild von
da die auf instagram gefunden die
kätzchen ist soll das ist eine
wundervolle caption und das ist das foto
meine damen und herren also wir sehen
hier die mit einem echten iphone iks hat
sich hier im spiegel fotografiert macht
hier auch noch werbung für was auch
immer das ist wunderschönes bild auch so
typischen instagram filter benutzt dann
hat sie danach dieses bild hier
hochgeladen und danach das
bild ich könnt euch nicht sagen dass das
navi ist ich wollte sagen lassen uns
vielleicht doch mal babys erstes
instagram bild anschauen aber sie hat
1300 beiträge warum haben denn die
ganzen youtube darin so unfassbar viel
hochgeladen ich meine julie und ich wir
haben 200 bilder oder irgendwie so hoch
deswegen auch nicht so viele follower
träumt jetzt auf meinem instagram jeden
tag zehn neue bilder
wenn ich ganz ganz viel lust am
fotografieren dann auch 50 pro tag ich
bin jetzt froh dass sie zumindest gerade
im wlan bin und dass das ganze ein
bisschen schneller lädt aber warum lädt
man so viel hoch ich meine babys fall
1350 bilder das ist jeden tag ein bild
über vier jahre
nein ich bin von der seite weggegangen
beschweren kann ich mich da
normalerweise eher weniger also bei dem
ganzen runterscrollen hier sieht man ja
ab und zu auch für einzelne bilder auf
die man sich dann ganz kurz fokussiert
und wobei kurzes augenmerk drauf hält
und bibi lädt echt sehr oft sachen hoch
die sehr sehr komisch sind
beispielsweise wohin habe ich einfach
ein bild gesehen von einem affen
oh mein gott
ich habe dass er
mit gefunden sie hat das bild vom mehr
als viereinhalb jahren hochgeladen die
kätzchen ist tunesien herz und sie
reitet auf einem kamel
mit julian co
kamel scheint spaß
hier noch ein bild wo sie im meer
hochspringt sommerfeeling herz nennt sie
das hier
fach
ohne caption nichts geht über ein
gemütliches schaumbad hat sie jedoch
hochgeladen
hier wieder ohne kätzchen hieß es
splittert orte mit erdbeeren man gönnt
sich ja sonst nichts
ja das waren babys erste instagram
beiträge felix ihn schauen wir uns mal
als nächstes an er hat 700 hoch gelandet
wie felix ist also auch soviel
hochgeladen gehört dass neuerdings solle
neue instagram taktik funktionieren soll
dass man irgendwie jeden tag ein bild
hochlädt und im gleichen moment aber ein
altes bild löscht so dass man quasi bei
null bleibt aber natürlich gar keinen
bock haben immer wieder zurück zu
scrollen und ein altes bild zu löschen
da irgendwie so aber wir sind ja gerade
auf dem profil von felix jeden schauen
mal was sein erstes hochgeladenes
instagram bild ist hashtag london punkt
und bilder aus dem fenster vom flieger
ja das ist felix erst hochlandes
instagram bild das er
ja felix
davis sowohl in london und hat sein
instagram bildern sind tatsächlich auch
schon krasse dj beiträge wo er irgendwie
war im wald steht beispielsweise aber
auf jeden fall auch krass dass er auch
so flugplan hat er die jetzt gar nicht
mal gedacht aber auch er kommt natürlich
auch trance um mit der ganzen sache als
nächsten youtuber habe ich hier in scope
21.300 dicker war umlage die alle so
viel hoch mache ich irgendwas falsch
folgt wir mal ich habe jetzt mehr hoch
nicole ist beispielsweise bilder hoch
wie wenn er hier im dschungel ist da
habe ich ihn letztens einfach das
angebot gemacht welt meld dich wenn du
personal training braucht weil ich
freunde ihr seht schon ich bin ein tier
nichts gegen dich nie chor bei der 200
konnte desto fetter wie hast du das hier
ist auch ein sehr schönes bild was
gerade einfach so random darauf gefloppt
ist ja echt mega lustig was man hier bei
nico für beiträge auf seinem instagram
findet alter leute check das auf jeden
fall mal ab das ist er komplett auch das
erste bild
da max und nico in action doppelpunkt de
dann haben wir hier noch personen die
kamera guckt hier noch mit einem mädel
dann hier wie man eine shisha bar und
sieht mensch nicolas aber augen gesund
da ist jetzt glaube ich auch der moment
gekommen wo wir dass bei nico einfach
mal beenden sollten
das was jetzt ihr vom video meine damen
und herren wenn es euch gefallen hat das
gerne mal einen like da schreibt man in
die kommentare instagram und folgt auf
jeden fall haben nämlich laser luca da
werden ganz bestimmt drei millionen
bilder pro tag
das war's jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten mal einen
schock aus checken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnenten zeit könnt ihr auch die
glocke klicken dann bekommt die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]